es ist wirklich der absolute wahnsinn
und es ist noch ein geheim- rekord aber
wissenschaftler rund um die erde
sprechen von einem der großen
wissenschaftlichen momente vergleichbar
mit dem ersten satelliten in der
erdumlaufbahn sputnik dem ersten
motorflug der gebrüder wright oder
einfach nur von einem bemerkenswerten
meilenstein google hat mit einem
quantencomputer eine berechnung in drei
minuten und 20 sekunden bewerkstelligt
für die die aktuell leistungsfähigsten
supercomputer rund 10.000 jahre
benötigen würden
google hat damit die quanten
überlegenheit erreicht klicks zum
science fiction gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und activity glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen das ist ein absoluter
gänsehautmoment der wissenschaft google
hat etwas absolut einmaliges erreicht
zum ersten mal hat ein quantencomputer
eine rechenaufgabe mit offensichtlich
geringer fehlerquote errechnet für die
ein aktueller supercomputer rund achtung
1,6 milliarden mal länger rechnen müsste
10.000 jahre statt drei minuten und 20
sekunden
diesen vergleich muss man sich nur mal
auf der zunge zergehen lassen damit
rücken tatsächlich unglaubliche
anwendung für quantencomputer in
greifbare nähe
in zukunft könnten wahnsinnig komplexe
modelle durchgerechnet werden zum
beispiel der bank sind mit allen
möglichen folgen für wirtschaft und
gesellschaft normale computer scheitern
heute noch an solchen aufgaben
quantencomputer haben überhaupt die
möglichkeit bei rechenaufgaben mit so
vielen unbekannten eine menge mögliche
szenarien zu bestimmen wofür moderne
computer eine ewigkeit brauchen oder es
einfach gar nicht hinkriegen können
quantencomputer viel viel schneller
rechnen weil sie alles gleichzeitig
machen können denn die quanten die
sogenannten kubitz befinden sich in
einer super position nicht wie bei dem
computer im zustand 0 oder 1 sondern in
weiten zuständen ein qubit befindet sich
also in zwei zuständen zwei coups in 43
in 84 in 16 5 in 32 und so weiter und
wie beim schach brennt auf das auf ein
feld immer doppelt so viele reisen
wie auf das feld da vorgelegt werden
müssen kommen am ende absurd hohe zahlen
heraus quantencomputer können damit
extrem komplexe probleme lösen für die
wir ansonsten extrem ausgefuchste
algorithmen benötigen würden und damit
dann extrem lange rechnen müssten
quantencomputer können das eben
gleichzeitig und kommen auf ein ergebnis
wie jetzt bei diesem absoluten
meilenstein der gugl kranken computer
hat 53 cubes damit kann er nicht 32 oder
64 zustände gleichzeitig annehmen
sondern achtung unglaubliche neun
milliarden also nicht unglaubliche
milliarden nicht absolut wahnsinnige
billionen sondern absolut abgefahren
unfasslich im bilden eine zahl mit 15 0
das ist außerhalb jeglicher superlative
forschende rechnen jetzt mit
fortschritten bei vielen komplexen
problemen medikamentenforschung
berechnung in der logistik
finanzwirtschaft datensicherheit alles
felder wo wir mit der heutigen computer
technologie an grenzen stoßen
das google 76 köpfige google quantum
team also das knie quanten team das sich
mit künstlicher intelligenz und
quantencomputern beschäftigt auch noch
eine sehr interessante perspektive hat
diesen rekord jetzt aufgestellt und
spricht selbst von einem meilenstein
diese kanten überlegenheit wurde damit
zum ersten mal erreichte damit laut der
definition des physikers john prescott
beschrieben dass ein quantencomputer
eine aufgabe bewältigt die für einen
herkömmlichen supercomputer unlösbar ist
allerdings ist das papier zu diesem
meilenstein noch geheim die nasa hatte
es kurz veröffentlicht und dann wieder
zurückgezogen uns liegt es vor und es
wird weltweit für authentisch und echt
gehalten und dem team wird respektvoll
will oliver vom massachusetts institute
of technology stellt ein vergleich mit
dem ersten motor flug der gebrüder
wright an frank villmow von der
universität des saarlandes vergleicht es
mit dem ersten satelliten in eine
erdumlaufbahn sputnik und intels quanten
chef james clark nennt es einen
bemerkenswerten meilenstein
quantencomputer erklärt von doktor
watson in diesem video anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren
der absolut sensationelle kanal
wer einen blick in die zukunft werfen
wollt also bis dann bleibt dran